I am barely getting on down here good
luck up there I did have fun don't get
me wrong you can look back on those
videos and I was going
Haywire but I cannot have any of this
and sadly well that's fitting for me hi
everyone it's Millie Bobby Brown here
and I am here with BuzzFeed to answer 30
questions as quickly as I can
a banana
my mum
love Community loss
oh open one present big or small
Christmas Eve and my fragrance wildly me
sit at home and make a chicken pot pie
Boogie Wonderland
nacho cheese Doritos which I've just had
men holding umbrellas
I am barely getting on down here good
luck up there
caring for the elderly
absolutely nothing my mum does not cook
and my dad makes me beans on toast like
the most minimal simple thing but it
actually hits every time
are you actually coming to see me
the drew me do moisturizer
Megan the stallion
confused
Unleashed
I don't have either of those things so I
I received many from my mum
um I have been contemplating blocking
her she sends me a sad sad tick tocks of
dogs being rehabilitated
um but I've now had to come you know
forward and tell her I cannot have any
of this and sadly because I walk right
onto stage for something really
important and I just watched you know a
cat be hit by a car so I'm like this is
not something that I want to ever be
sent to me ever again she's like you
know but it does happen I'm like let's
not make this normal this isn't normal
so we've had made an agreement now that
only happy videos thus far
mini golden doodle puppies for sale
that's fitting for me
19 steps
go to a concert Taylor Swift the last
time I went you know it was amazing but
every song I sang you know and I really
put my hole into I was like oh there's
like you know thousands of phones
pointing at me and I really just wanted
to you know have fun and I did have fun
don't get me wrong you can look back on
those videos and I was going
Haywire but um I think I would enjoy
just being able to like blend in and
have a bit more fun
uh last great American Dynasty
most of my talents are useful
barking
that's true yes I'm a very good Barker
nope
lilac
the dog emoji
New Zealand
settings I'm always changing my time
me and my fiancee
oh uh chocolate chip chocolate chip
definitely or vanilla
his name is Coco he's brown I got him a
day before I left so when I get back
he's gonna be a bit bigger but I can't
wait to see him
I like to be in control of just my whole
life and every decision ever which is
good and bad that it's just like okay
like I like to make the schedule and the
itinerary for the for the week and
everybody must be punctual
no no I pretend they don't exist
don't let anyone dull my Sparkle
my fiance and then my mum usually on a
group call
Bluey
so good
oh sheesh very good very good it's like
a feast when you're there and it's all
my favorite foods so there you go or
just go to a pub and have a good roast
dinner thank you guys so much for
watching this video I hope you learned
more about me be sure to read my new
novel 19 steps and to smell my new
fragrant wildly me thank you guys so
much for watching see you soon
thank you